[Applause]
right hi guys
hi ladies
[Applause]
so three sisters yes you're not the
sister are you
no brother-in-law brother-in-law now
tonight is all about good food made fast
yeah
we haven't started cooking it's the heat
are you ready yes okay we're ready jane
and cuthbert that side wendy alice on
this side yes okay lovely
okay good thank you right wendy yes chef
the menu what is it
the menu tonight chef is for our starter
we've got
a fresh tuna with
oh holy [ __ ] i'm now starting to [ __ ]
myself i've never cooked anything
you're sweating like a [ __ ]
okay it's a seared tuna salad nicoise
okay that was a [ __ ] start
yeah it was fun it was it was terrible
let's do the first table together
time six minutes for the eggs let's do
the first time together right listen
the only thing we're cooking is a tuna
at the last minute and the eggs
three or four potatoes each yes a
handful of beans
yes yes pitted olives shallot rings yes
cherry tomatoes yes yes yes what are
they called anchovies
anchovy phillips good dress that that's
done olive oil in the pan nice and hot
in literally one minute each side yeah
turn turn it bring the heat back up into
the pan
that's vinegar and we just go over
[Music]
the oven sliced careful i don't want it
ripped look
seared beautifully pink in the center
eggs out please
then from there open where's the ace
eggs
now i'm sorry but there's nothing
difficult there is there no let's go
good girl good girl come on jealous
careful careful careful [ __ ] i want
you like a [ __ ] like a china shop
watch up and then oh [ __ ] oh it's a bit
yeah that's nice look listen to me
perfect
sit that there and let it drizzle inside
and that there
is fit for a king right would you pay
for that yeah yeah cuff book that's
certainly
you haven't touched it and you still
would do it let's go i can't
tonight's brigade is wendy allison jane
and cuthbert
well as you can see by my physique i
really do love food
i got a brawl i want to taste what they
cook and if i don't like it at least
i've tried it
i do love cooking since i've been the
age of eight i've been cooking
some people find cooking or i've got to
go and cook dinner but when i get up in
the morning i
wonder what am i gonna cook for that
evening meal well my favorite
is i like doing fish and chips i use a
nice pint of lager in me better
family is very important to us there are
so many of us you don't need anyone else
if you've got family and you're close
i think me alice and wendy have always
enjoyed cooking you do them too little
it's little tiny bits
alison will definitely call sparks in
the kitchen with golden and they both
know about the f word
i'm the most aggressive i definitely am
i know that but it's probably because
i'm going for your change i don't know
i believe we are going to be the best
brigade gordon has ever had
eat you're right i have mr ramsey we're
on yeah
two couples table nine two seventy's one
two roast chicken two apple and pear
right cuff button yes two tuna salads
two tuna shreds one egg for two portions
you've got four [ __ ] eggs in there
sorry chef
one egg two portions one egg two pounds
let's go big man so we want two chef
cuff book yeah one egg two portions
sorry chef right listen yes one should
be dressed in the salad
yeah why should we get the tuna ready
who's doing the salad i'm doing tuna oh
[ __ ] man you're doing the salad
[ __ ] lauren harness this is another
fine mess i got myself into toughbook
you know alison get that pan nice and
hot try it again nice and hot it won't
get any older than any quicker
ready chef
to send them up the property ladder
jack you're scaring them
right guys come here quick right no
my gorgeous lamb charlotte and gavin are
now nine weeks old putting on two kilos
a week
my flock is eating me out of house and
home
hugh furley whittingstall suggested i
find new pasture as fresh grass will
help keep their mothers producing rich
milk
and good grazing will give charlotte and
gavin great flavor
vaughan's got astro turf and you've got
no grass left is that right
sorry i can't help dan that's a no
actually you've really seriously pulled
me out of the [ __ ] i can assure you
thank you
oh that's no problem bye charlotte
mcgavin
see you in two weeks today
is moving day but moving livestock is
not my bag
luckily hugh has volunteered to help
hopefully he also knows how to dismantle
a sheep hud i really hate diy you're not
telling me who
where they're going gordon she has an
amazing
it's a she is it yes an amazing garden
yeah has it got a decent bit of grass on
it
yes it's got long grass [ __ ] literally
your poo bin is leaking up
and now i've been electrocuted oh yeah
you're worse than tana
you know what gordon what you've even
got a builder's crack
sorry we need to spread straw in the
trailer to make the sheep comfortable
during the journey
just so that they think of the trailer
as being a nice place to be
it also helps you to feel at home no
huge stop [ __ ] around
i'm gonna look like you now [ __ ] you
stop [ __ ] around
come on there you go they're all off how
easy is that like
it's common practice for farmers like
you to move sheep from parsley to
pasture
you'll be right just just go on the
trailer will follow
but not so usual in south west london
anymore i can't believe how good they
were getting in there yeah they'll be
quite comfy back there
i'll find out later or hugh makes of
their new home
i loved it i adore tuna anyway the tuna
was cooked
superbly it was a little bit pink and
the eggs were very flavoursome they were
lovely the tuna was well cooked if a
little bit cold all in all i enjoyed it
yes results uh jb here we go
so for the starters
37 out of 15.
you got 37 out of 50. okay
next on the menu the foodie gobshite
gives me another mouthful
i can't believe i'm 40 years of age and
janice reporters have blind feeding me
yeah just look at it as kinky sex oh my
god
the brigade serves up a delicious main
course of chicken in a morel source
with seasonal asparagus and eccentric
talent scout david guess
helps me my search for a new female cook
we i found a vagina cup we can find him
a fairy
welcome back to the f word now time for
the main course uh no stop stop stop
stop
they're burn pad fried chicken breasts
with morel sauce
chicken is the nation's favorite meat
we've roasted it we've stir-fried it
we've curried it
this is a new dimension so with a
wonderful rich morel sauce
just before it goes in the pan get your
cloth and just pat it dry
that gets rid of any excess moisture
therefore when it goes in the pan it
doesn't spit at you
season skin side down
into the pan garlic
thyme knob of butter in
straight into the oven eight to ten
minutes 180 degrees
mural sauce and the most important thing
about these dried morals is you just add
boiling water it rehydrates the mushroom
then there's an added bonus
you've got your own mushroom stock drain
off
and mushrooms into the pan
garlic thyme
splashing white wine the white wine
starts to sweeten it up
mushroom stock reduce
cream bring that out to the boil
and literally just cook it for one
minute and the secret now
is to pass the sauce through the sieve
get your ladle
and just push wonderful color not too
thick
and full of flavor perfect asparagus
they're in season
and it's british cut off the bottom part
of the spear
that's the woody part don't throw away
great for stocks
and great for soups first we're going to
cook them from raw
on a griddle pan olive oil
[Applause]
fresh morel mushrooms just cut them into
halves
so to the mushroom hot olive oil fresh
thyme
and finish at the very end with a touch
of butter
and we're ready to serve
start from the top and just slice in
half
add fresh morel mushrooms sauce
over goodbye stir fry goodbye roast
chicken
no more curries that's british at its
best
pan fried chicken with morel sauce
[Music]
[Applause]
don't keep on mushing them in a way that
they get too
broken up be very careful right that's a
nice color on there good swap
nice mushrooms nice hot pan you do not
boil the mushrooms you saute the
mushrooms yes
yes cheddar alison look at your sauce
yeah look at your sauce
let's go taste the sauce wendy
don't get it too dark those pans have
always got to be hard
alison yeah shape alison yes
mushroom good slice of the chicken right
yes yes okay look on the hot plate
way deep this is what i'm trying to say
but
we've got things we're supposed to do
you put the food in the bowl first the
chicken gets sliced last
yes potatoes aren't cooked mushrooms
aren't out the pan and now you want to
argue so i'm just trying to get you
organized
stop slicing the chicken for five
minutes and help get the food in the
[ __ ] bowl
right where's the bowl watch out here is
the biggest gob in the food world
pressed foie gras marinated in white
pool
foie gras marinated in pinot noir
caramel
or this menu honey and soy roasted quail
with foie gras
and spiced pear chutney well if you ask
me gordon is bloody obsessed with foie
gras
if you go through the menus of his
restaurants
photograph features on nearly every one
foie gras is a foodie's delight it has a
unique buttery taste and texture that
makes it often
irresistible but the trouble is the way
that the french make it is by
force feeding ducks and geese holding
their beaks open
and shoving down a lot of food and quite
frankly that's a bit repulsive isn't it
well i think the french think that foie
gras is a french
food nobody else can produce it and they
own the copyright on it if you like
but that french monopoly is now being
challenged by a so-called ethical foie
gras from spain
i want to know if the french and spanish
products can even compare
if they can i'm going to challenge
gordon to change his mind
and his menus to get to the bottom of
all this who are about foie gras i've
decided to come to the heart of rural
france to the door dine
and pay my first visit ever to a foie
gras
farm
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign it's cruel
no it's not cruel it's not crap
if i go there yeah and you're lucky okay
look at this lot they're not rushing
so that makes me think they don't really
want that they are friends
i'm told the birds on this farm receive
six kilos of grain a day
it's the actual business of putting the
tube down the throat that i find quite
hard to look at
french farmers insist that only force
feeding
can create the taste and texture what
seems like a cruel way of producing a
delicacy
is simply a continuation of a
centuries-old tradition
i know the most intelligent animals but
they must have a little brain
and do they really like this i mean the
pluses have had a massive dinner
the downside is their life's gonna end
in a few days time
he's part animal ten days more
life death wrong and probably the last
nightmare he's going to have his janet
street porter holding him
after two to three weeks of force
feeding the liver is at its most
engorged and the duck is slaughtered
look how big it is
disgusting the liver is 10 times bigger
than normal
and it's this unnatural amount of fat
that creates the distinctive taste
now i'm having second thoughts
devil's food i wasn't very happy
seeing how the geese were fed it's given
me a lot to think about
and probably i'm gonna have nightmares
now
not very happy about it at
all and i won't be eating it anymore
definitely
[Music]
now what's really pissed the french off
is that the spanish producers have won
the prestigious medal for innovation
at the paris international food salon
and they're not happy
now it's time to put this spanish
product to the test
if i'm to have any hope of changing
gordon's mind
i've got to find him an alternative that
rivals the taste of the french
how many geese are here
six thousand case where are they
farmer eduardo explains that if we kneel
down the geese will come
freely to us i'm gonna pray to a ghost i
can't believe i'm gonna do this
each year the geese binge eat local
acorns and olives to prepare for their
migration
so what this is like a five-star hotel
luxury hotel for geese but unlike most
hotels the best fed guests
get slaughtered how do you know when the
liver
is ready when they are ready to be um
they eat non-stop sounds like a lot of
people i know eduardo
seeing the birds in their natural
environment was a refreshing sight
but i couldn't help wondering would
their livers be as stuffed with fat as
their ethical credentials
now i can already say that this is much
smaller than the french liver
that is an ethical goose liver
but most crucially would the spanish
taste as good as the french
i'm gonna taste it
delicious very good water
well this product has got all the taste
and none of the cruelty
[Music]
tastes bloody marvelous this is
food that you can eat with a clear
conscience so i'm going to go back home
i'm going to bloody going to force feed
it
excuse me just [ __ ] off right
why oh why do you have foie gras on all
of your
menu this is
god jesus christ have you got hearing
aid because you're shouting so much more
than laughter
because they're all frying behind have
you got a hearing aid in there no of
course not just
they don't want me okay can we do a deal
here
if you can't tell the difference between
the ethical foie gras
and the horrible chew down your gourd
foie gras okay
that you serve yes the ethical far grass
trust me if i cannot tell the difference
i will serve it in my restaurant okay
okay off we go first one here's the
first one okay thank you
all
right
i like you with a blindfold stop getting
kinky for god's sake right have you
swallowed it yet
oh my god okay please i can't believe
i'm 40 years of age and janice reporters
blind feeding me
yeah thank you just look at it as kinky
sex oh my god
right get on with it
first one was very smooth and it sort of
you know it sort of lined the
roof of my mouth the second one was a
lot rougher but didn't have the impact
of the richness of a fargo
which one would you like to serve in
your restaurant uh
definitely the first one smooth and yeah
yeah the second one
is the ethical one which goes to show
the
it doesn't mind listen listen
excuse me that confirms that my palace
ten times better than yours
jb help janet back to her wheelchair
please let's go
30 seconds guys i'm sorry but this is
one hour
and 20 minutes i've got enough potatoes
here for two
jane you're part of this everyone just
disappears when it gets to the
this is the exciting part yeah no one's
here is this okay chef
right that one's got no sauce that one's
got sauce that was all splattered at the
side
i'm not gonna argue just get some sauce
on there okay dirty plate
dirty plate dirty plastic come and clean
the plates what are you doing
right no [ __ ] all's next too late i
can't ask these people
hey to pay you've got to serve them but
they are not expected to pay
one hour 25 minutes quickly sorry about
the why
that did not need to be that hard you're
a family there's nothing close knit and
what you've just done in the last hour
no teamwork thank you that's right now
for the dessert
you have to work as a team you were
slicing
yes chicken and wendy wasn't oblivious
that you're doing it and all i said to
you from the out
i did say get [ __ ] place that chef not
blaming wendy but she's a [ __ ] i did
say get the plates out i did
did i did i not say get them done i did
not say get the plates out
it's not about playing it's about
working together for the desserts
we have to work together
david good to see you man how are you
are you well i'm very good
guys ladies good evening how's the main
course
excellent this was good you enjoyed it
yes yeah really good the chicken was
nice the mushrooms are nice
yeah would you pay for that i didn't you
invited me as your guest
you can afford 12 pounds can't you eight
pound for the starter no
you suck you won't pay 12 pounds for
that
i have a gift for you oh already yes
that's very kind
thank you my housekeeper vagina
cassieman
right is this person real she's real she
wants you to know
she is writing her own cookbook the
vagina casement
cookbook and she has a very special
semen cake
very salty but you're going to get it
she's sending female this is from
vaginica
cup links a blind man made them for her
but there's a v
for vaginica you're a very generous man
yes
now you were married to liza yes did you
have a cook for her
no she once cooked for me she used a lot
of wine
were you i just was joking lawyers i
give the right amendment
she didn't use wine she used beer and
she used vodka
okay did you ever argue over food no
because we both like the same foods and
she would always steal from my plate
nightstill from her plate yes we
she she had a great appetite now you've
got an eye for talent
very much so i've been searching to find
a new talented female cook i need your
help now
get the word out there spread the word
to the nation
right and i think this is going to be
right up your street i want you to get
it down the street
find me i love it okay
i will yes please she's that word on
greece
i found a vagina coat we can find him a
fanny
thank you it's been a pleasure i love
you i love it
don't forget that t-shirt yes i won't
thank you
holy [ __ ] what in the [ __ ] is he on
mine's okay a little unseated possibly
but um no i really enjoyed it
the potatoes were a bit hard al dente
is nice for vegetables and pasta but not
potatoes
okay um we were slow what a shape
here we go let's find out how many
customers out of 50 paid
for the main i mean
30 customers paid for the main course
30 30. 20 didn't sorry chef
for what reason what they say so
obviously too long too long again
raw potatoes a bit bland
yeah but we didn't have potatoes on the
main meal
let's get 50 out of 50 yes
paying for the dessert yes
next on the menu blurs alex james takes
me on in the recipe challenge
alex is using hay i'm not because it's
[ __ ] disgusting
if the cockney tits up when desserts get
burnt all the others if you look i'll
put them in the [ __ ] bean
i missed one and i become the deer
hunter
now no
welcome back to the f-word now time for
me to beat alex james in the recipe
challenge
ready ready right what am i doing what
are you doing alex
i'm doing breast of lamb breast of lamb
rolled and stuffed up with mushrooms
bake it in hay on a bed of spinach with
uh some baked shallots
nothing fancy you are quite a secret
little foodie aren't you
i do love my well when you live in the
country kind of life does tend to
revolve around food really i mean you
take all day making uh
making dinner rumor has it you're
turning into a bit of a sort of shoe
early witting still yes
the sort of the trout farm phase of the
sort of rock star
trajectories is inevitable as the uh
sort of model chasing
boozy phase you know so alex is doing
the stuff
breast of lamb i'm gonna do a saddle of
land stuff with wild mushrooms sage a
little bit of mint
and some mascarpone cheese band together
with some spinach
um alex is using hay i'm not because
it's [ __ ] disgusting
why hey it's nice it gives it a nice it
does give it a nice flavor i'm gonna
give it a bit of a scorch so you get
like caramelized hay
so it's gonna be a bit sweeter you're
getting really fast i'm going at the
city speed
you're going at the country speed yeah
it's very hard for me to imagine that
you're a rock star and now you're this
laid back countryman
can you see through all that hair alex
yeah man
coming through so you're looking through
one eye yeah
if i get this right it's flash so you've
got mushrooms in there
yeah just giving it a little roll nice
huh it's
quite a well trimmed piece actually yeah
then you'll tie that in string
yeah if i can that's the tricky bit
excellent
very chefy that you know that okay okay
after so many years as a highly
successful band yeah and a rock and roll
lifestyle to go with it don't you miss
it
i kind of i wouldn't like to think
there'd never be another blur record but
i don't i don't sort of yearn for it no
i think it's you know it's a hard thing
to sort of leave behind
of course but um i think it you know
it's been good that there's not been
sort of a blur record for a while
because we all kind of needed to learn
how to sort of
be grown-ups yep and that looks all
right yeah
i tell you what from uh from a chef's
point of view it looks like it's tied
nice and tightly and more importantly
now you've stuffed it nothing's leaking
out
this is right the guy who sold me my
pigs i showed him this hay and he said
that's too good for a pig
you're serious so what do you do with
the hate you've wet it alex wet it and
then give it a bit of a t
i haven't tried this before now you're
going to set fire to it
you're like a countryside arsenic i
can't believe you said fire to the
hattie
alex it looks like a large burs nest yes
so mushrooms are in there spinach is in
there i'm just gonna season it now with
some lightly grated nutmeg
salt pepper and a tablespoon of
mascarpone cheese
bind all those mushrooms and the eggs
together and stuff that
inside the saddle of lamb alex
you wrapped the breast in hay you then
wrapped it in cling film
now you've wrapped it in tin foil what's
next
carpet what are you doing look at that
can't argue with that mate that's that's
posh yeah that yeah
but
someone's gonna fold mine sage on top
little phillips on top
and then just wrap nice and tightly over
hoping all that stays in there so the
idea of the hay is to what perfume it
yeah it does give it gives it a bit of
flavor you know and then uh
it keeps it quite moist as well actually
so then you just give it a little
fry at the end oh so you're crisping
yours now i'm gonna criss it up get it
really nice and uh crispy on the outside
seasoned it
and once it's all sealed then i can put
it in the oven it'd be very hard to get
this color on the oven straight away
sure
ready into the oven 30 minutes each
yeah i'll go to the top shelf just in
there like that yes yeah
okay good yeah 30 minutes um now i want
to talk to you about your
unusual sort of uh calcium intake ah
you once drank your wife's breast milk i
did what's all that about
well she had twins and she'd been in
hospital for like three months with them
and then she got out and went to see the
foo fighters
had a few beers right the milk was
condemned so i didn't want to throw it
away it's got to be good for you
it's got uh less fat more protein it's
got to be better for you than cow's milk
i mean it's
it's human milk you're looking at me now
if you just put it in your [ __ ] new
cheese recipe have you made cheese with
it yet
people have tried but it won't coagulate
but we could do a pretty good
cappuccino you up for it with
breast milk rock and roll
now time to see if the companies know
their apples and pears
[Music]
apples and pears are perfect dessert for
this time of year this
is a braeburn apple nice and crisp full
of juice hardly any acidity
this is a comet's pair now quite robust
quite dense in the center but the most
amazing flavor
very very sweet right when we caralize
through you've got to core the center
down in twist and pull out
nice thin slices as you feel the secret
behind roasting apples and pears is
making sure
that they're not too ripe if they're
slightly too ripe
then the whole thing disintegrates in
the pan look at that smells
amazing
and now we're gonna form a really nice
caramel but we're gonna season this can
with black pepper star neat and close
and that gives a really nice spice
flavor when you're caramelizing the
apples and pears
pan sugar get it really nice and even
therefore the caramel starts cooking
evenly and doesn't burn in the corners
butter stops it from separating and
splitting
spice cinnamon stick pears
and apples in put the fat side down and
now that i'm happy with that color i'm
going to add my calvados
and it sort of enriches the camera jesus
[Music]
then finished with apple juice it just
sort of
liquefies the caramel and just takes the
heaviness out of it
bring that to the boil and just coat
the apples and pears and let it glaze
over
and serve that smells amazing now just
finish that
with some ice cream on caramelise apples
and pears with ice cream
done we serve
the madeline because it's a really nice
accompaniment
it's like a nice little sort of baked
sponge once you've tasted
the perfect madeline yes trust me you'll
never ever forget it
50 like that and they're all going to
pay for it yes yes yes
right first of all madeline's in one
mile do you mean that i've pulled all
the pays i'm doing the payments
i'm doing the atkins
apple juice last wash your fingers pull
it back
get the bottle away from the flame
you'll go up in a [ __ ] oh
that's it let's go should we send that
please
keep the pan don't toss it with cavitos
in there you'll [ __ ] set yourself on
fire
come on we can do this girl come on come
here come on
come on come on careful careful careful
careful careful you're gonna
really hurt yourself yeah very careful
now
everyone's laughing and [ __ ] around let
me just show you something hello look
there you go yeah that's just come back
so john please turn it open check it
right now right now you're all making
yourself look [ __ ] stupid
okay so hey i know no no don't chef me
no yeah don't check me there because i
didn't have nowhere to put the other
twice
quickly listen listen don't serve black
madeline's end the story okay chef
that was a mishap all the others if you
look i'll put them in the [ __ ] bin
i missed one sorry come back yeah guys i
said i missed one
every other madeline that's burned is in
the bin i threw him in there
a monster at least one just sent it back
no i'm not arguing i'm apologizing
because i thought
because i thought i got them all off
that's the standard of your apology
hello hey
sorry chef i am sorry chef
all right these ones are burnt as well
chef could that be the big one
there you go have a look right are they
burnt aren't they [ __ ] underneath
while deer are the most loved and
respected of game
[Music]
they're beautiful majestic creatures
whilst their meat is widely regarded as
the most regal of delicacies
now i've been given the chance to hunt
and kill a deer myself
i'm in the middle of forest here in
thetford right in the heart of norfolk
i've never shot a deer i've never been
stalking before and i cannot wait
i've always wanted to stalk wild deer
it's one of the ultimate standoffs
between man and beast
a centuries-old tradition with a huge
payoff a chance to eat some of the
finest game in the world
[Music]
alan how are you sir hi gordon welcome
to that
expert deer hunter alan mccormick is
going to show me the ropes
it doesn't sound easy and what you're
looking at doing is lining up on the
back
of the leg right and it's a third to
halfway up and essentially
that's going to go through the vital
organs of the heart and lungs and the
deer and that's a clean
that's a clean shot okay good excellent
how exciting you know you can see that
okay nice and steady three nut breezes
squeeze when you're ready
stags can weigh up to 350 kilo almost
four times my weight
and it takes great skill to kill a fully
grown deer humanely
and of course the problem is is that if
you need that second shot
we need to then sort it out quickly i
only hope i can make the all-important
clean kill
when it's my time to pull the trigger oh
[ __ ]
i can't see any holes there oh there's
one there's two
oh three goals now every one of those
shots would have taken that deer and
killed it
really outright you're obviously a
driven and competitive person this isn't
a competition we've got to wait till
this is all right absolutely and every
time it's right then it's fine shots on
we take off
well done we'll hunt for real tomorrow
in the meantime alan's got some fresh
venison liver from a kill first thing
this morning
it will make the perfect hunter's meal
what fascinates me with this particular
dish is that the deer stalkers back in
the early days would sort of
treat this as their main meal fry up
some shallots
pancetta a bit of wild garlic
and some mushrooms that smells [ __ ]
delicious
just leave them there i'm just going to
do a really nice sort of crouton
for the bacon to sit on into the olive
oil and now for the liver
it's times like this i feel a little bit
like hannibal lecter nice big thick
slices
it's really important when you're
cooking with liver just season the liver
at the very last minute
otherwise it dries out look at the
colour of that liver
one minute each side pan smoking
almost treat it like you're cooking a
nice piece of fillet steak a tail piece
of fillet
and i'll tell you what it doesn't become
any fresher than that
i'm surprised there's no more deer that
rock up that smells amazing
right look at that man
that's so rich that is nice that really
is nice
it's off to bed early to rise the stalk
starts at dawn
we need to be really quiet here okay you
could have a deer at any point anywhere
the plan is to stalk in silence before
we see a deer
then take aim and fire but with a film
crew a thick mist and my inexperience
that's easier said than done there's two
deer just down the side of the field
[ __ ] they're just gone
[Music]
after two hours of trudging around on
the ground we still had no luck
it was time to move to a high seat which
in this weather should give us more
chance
okay take as much time as you
can need oh what's that there
yeah it's a hair i love her look good
lovely hannah wasn't he
can i take him out no you bloody won't
yeah what do you do when you're this
high up on your desperate need for
number two
oh there you go it's just come out and
stuff yeah steady steady steady
it's all right but they may come back
again
i know it's too far there it is steady
there they are steady for a clean quick
kill
idea needs to be side on and standing
still
come on little bastard turn side on
no no no no
no so frustrating damn
there is a condition called buck fever
and it's essentially when people get
excited and they're
about anticipation and adrenaline of
trying to a bit like a book now
exactly there's another one there's
another one
anytime now
finally after hours of stalking i had
the perfect clear shot of a beautiful
wild deer
in my sides
but something didn't feel right you're
gonna have to do it shortly
instead of pulling the trigger i took my
finger off it
that was really frustrating after all
those hours spent stalking the deer and
then
the chase is exciting there's no toys
about that that's very sort of
boyish but it's really weird when you
get it in your sight and you think god
should pull that trigger or not
i don't know maybe i'm becoming a
vegetarian
[Music]
next on the menu alex james tries to
persuade me breast
is best i really like it alex
itching to know who owns my new pasture
i feel like i'm on through the keyhole
gordon i
can't imagine who lives here someone
with a bit more taste than you
that's for sure are you such a [ __ ]
and the eastenders find out if they've
done well enough to come back and cook
in my west end restaurant
results of the desserts out of 50 diners
welcome back to the f word now time for
the results of the recipe challenge time
to plate up
nervous i was a little bit nervous in
the kitchen are you serving with it
i'm gonna do a little bit of spinach and
shallots just smell this hay man it's
very small
it's quite honey honeys wouldn't you say
alex no it smells like a [ __ ] pigsty
it smells very sweaty smells good to me
i think getting the hay off the worst
the way those fingers are the way you're
roasting things with your fingers you're
not using anything
very chefy that you know that it's all
right be happy with that
i am yeah yeah so you should be jb yeah
so
roast belly of lamb yes stuff saddle of
lamb
ali the best choir hello
how are you so this is the stuff
number one okay
all right
moist very moist a little bit fatty
yeah beautifully cooked let's try the
other one shall we i like mine
a little bit more oh yeah i love the
flavor yeah good flavor coming through
mushrooms lovely that's a pee
that for me is absolutely sublime
well you've put me to the test i'm going
to put you to the test now okay i want
to see if you can taste one of my very
special
cappuccinos uh-huh with breast milk yeah
let's go for it
yeah can you froth breast milk
yeah it's all about how fresh the milk
is that's how well it froths
right okay
i can't believe you never tasted it
before no i'm not missing you know that
in
in california the ladies are all having
it after their pilates
no i'm scared breast milk cappuccino
on your cornflakes all over the place
it's sweet it's really sweet isn't it
[ __ ] lovely wow
i really like it alex
we get some more and if you have started
the new [ __ ] craigslist it's all your
fault you know that
okay right ready for results well i
wasn't happy with that at all [ __ ]
breast meat cappuccino
oh alex okay
give me good news because yeah one's
rolled and wrapped in hay i'm always a
beautiful salad of lamb
don't [ __ ] around no
okay so on this obviously you're doing
that yes in there yes
no well done mate thank you buddy good
luck with the christmas single come here
do me a favor yes [ __ ] up out my kitchen
get back to that cheese thank you alex
cheers mate
[Music]
today hugh is helping me transform my
lambs to pastures new
we arrive at my sheep's temporary new
home while the owner is still at work
happy with the grass i think i was
hoping for slightly more acreage
i'll admit it but look at the length of
this
what i like you know that's good grass
yeah well don't waste
it i'm gonna put it back down i'll make
you eat it i do not want to look
stupid in front of madam you know that
hang on you've got it on the hammer
you need to be able to see daylight yeah
i can see daylight now it's upside down
that's the back right oh is it the front
i'm intrigued i feel like i'm on through
the keyhole gorge
i i can't imagine who lives here someone
with a bit more taste than you
that's for sure are you such a [ __ ]
well
um she has a creative eye i think she'll
be pretty much impressed with
the way we put this together this
familiar little palace
will help my sheep adjust their new
environment and give them a shelter
place out of the rain
hello hello how are you well welcome
well
thank you how are you first of all a big
thing amazing
that's a pleasure thank you so much for
having them that's that's it pleasure
hello
how are you how are you good to see you
i haven't seen that you've been building
you've been the mystery guest all
afternoon i didn't know whose garden i
was in
i did say it was a woman of class and
taste though didn't i well i'm so glad
you recognized that
[Music]
look at that straight in hey
i'm liking
[Music]
do i need to read to them do you eat
them did you read them in your garden
when i come home at night sometimes and
to get them out
and i'd come by come by come by it's a
bit of a welsh thing
with me my shepherd you've got to try it
sir can you do that
okay go on so come by come by come by
too long yeah
you wait they're gonna be really really
looks after here they're gonna have a
lovely time
we're gonna be happy i do think that
happy meat tastes better
absolutely but any problems i'm only
five minutes down the road we'll get
some sun and rain
more grass no problem hope that shed
stays up i'll call you if it doesn't
the dessert was really delicious some of
the apples were a little bit undercooked
and a little bit hard to cut into
but the ice cream and the sauce was
really really delicious and i would
definitely pay for the dessert
the pears in the apple were really
really quite raw really hard to
bite couldn't even get your fork through
i scraped my plate clean the whole thing
was really delicious really complimented
each other really well and really tasty
good end to the meal let's go
ladies please here we go let's go let's
go let's go results for the desserts how
do you think you've done it we worked a
lot out of i think on the dessert the
team
we've done a bit more teamwork on the
dessert than we did on the
main so 37 out of 50 for starters 30 out
of 50 for maine
out of 50 diners yes
come on come on
29 and happy to pay for it oh my gosh
that's a grand total of 96
out of 150. oh my god that's terrifying
that's terrible
we are coming back if you worked harder
as a team and spent less time shout out
to you you could have achieved a little
bit more you could have done a lot
better
why are you so gobby i was trying to be
the leader yes
yes right there's only one [ __ ]
leader here